I JUST FLAT OUT FORGOT WE HAD A
CHIMP ON THE FORCE
YEAH. THAT WAS
A PUBLICITY STUNT.
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS.
IT WAS PUBLICITY.
Wiegel:
EVERYBODY WAS DOING
THAT IN THE EIGHTIES.
Jones:
THAT CHIMP WAS
AN ASS[BLEEP].
OH, THIS IS NOVEMBER 10.
Dangle on TV:
NO, I'M SERIOUS.
YOU COULD DO
"PLAYBOY" FOR REAL.
JIM, I'VE HAD IT WITH
THE INAPPROPRIATE
COMMENTS, FOR REAL.
WOW.
AND I KNOW IT'S A SOCK
IN YOUR PANTS.
I COULD DO "PLAYBOY."
Wiegel: RAY RAY,
COME ON. LET'S GO.
Big Mike on TV:
JIM, COME ON.
Travis: OH, THERE'S
LIEUTENANT MIKE.
YES. BEST LIEUTENANT
WE EVER HAD.
THAT'S BIG MIKE?
CRACKHEAD?
I THINK HE WAS ON HIS WAY
TO BEING GOVERNOR.
Big Mike on TV: OK.
ALL RIGHT, AFTER DANGLE,
WE'RE GOING IN HOT AND HARD,
ALL RIGHT?
YOU GO AHEAD, JIM. GO.
[BREAKS GLASS]
[FIRES GUN]
ON MY COUNT.
1, 2, 3.
[ALL SHOUTING]
I DON'T KNOW.
IS THIS ON?
Jones:
WHAT'S THAT?
Williams: THAT'S DEBBIE.
I KNOW WHAT THIS IS.
NO, NO, NO.
GIVE ME THAT.
NO.
OH, MY GOD.
THIS IS GONNA BE SO
GREAT TO SEE BACK.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW IF
THIS IS A SUPER
GREAT IDEA
TO TAPE
THIS, PER SE.
[ALL SHOUTING]
GIVE IT UP!
I DON'T FEEL ANYTHING.
I NEED TO MOVE
SOMETHING HERE.
HANG ON.
OOH. OOH.
NO, THAT'S MY LEG.
NO, THAT'S MY THIGH.
OK, CAN
I LIFT THIS UP?
YEAH.
IS THERE
A CANDLE
OR A FLASHLIGHT
OR ANYTHING
OVER THERE?
NO. NO.
OH, MY GOD.
HOW COULD YOU GO
DOWN THERE AFTER
YOU DESCRIBED
THAT SMELL?
OH, CRAP.
THAT'S REWIND.
All: AAH!
IT LOOKS LIKE SHE'S
GIVING BIRTH TO IT!